let's go next door caller from the 66
area code it's a wild day who's calling
today from 6:00 to 6:00 good morning
David this is Steven from Pasadena
California hey Steve are taking my call
my pleasure
and I'm gonna join as a member today
because I just love your show and you
inspire me and your mother all right
so I don't know if I can get two
questions in one will be fairly short
but we'll see I'll pass my first
question first all right so as you know
it's a safety measure well I was
scheduled to go to Vegas this weekend
MGM is temporarily closing their Las
Vegas buffet is in wake of the worldwide
potential pandemic is that right no that
scheduled to go to Vegas in April I go
twice ago for a conference and I've been
talking to people we just don't know
what's going to happen we don't know if
it'll hit Vegas in a more serious manner
yeah so right now MGM is closing on
their five properties they're their
major properties they are including Aria
and and others they're closing the
buffets every week they're gonna
re-evaluate okay
so my question is and and I'm so I was
going to see my family web we see each
other all the time so we're just going
to postpone until things hopefully
settle down but my question is do you
think that's an overt still measure or
do you think it makes sense and that you
see maybe other food establishments
following suit listen here's the thing I
am not qualified to comment on that and
I don't want to do so unlike Trump who
says doctors are shocked by how much he
knows about medical I am NOT an expert
on this I am going to go by what you
know emergency managers doctors etc say
here's what I can tell you though I'm
Steve if this all works right
Italy's closed Harvard all these
universities doing classes online
south-by-southwest
all this stuff it might feel like when
you look at the number of cases in the
US they claim it's about you know 1100
it's probably more like 6,000 if we were
testing broadly whatever imagine that
this works were at an inflection point
infections and transmission goes down
you're gonna have Monday Morning
Quarterback errs quarterbacks
saying this was too much it didn't make
any sense and they will be like the
anti-vaccine people who say measles is
so rare why do we need a vaccine well
it's rare because we've had a vaccine
for decades much the same way I think is
this too much is it not I don't know but
we've got to get it under control I have
things I want to be doing you know I
have immunocompromised people in my
family that I don't want exposed to this
so is it too much or not I don't know
but I'm gonna go by what the the public
health officials say okay does it make
you nuts when he come when Trump
compares it to the flu I mean yeah I
mean ignorance you know listen here's
the very good question Trump doesn't
know anything about this it is true that
the death rate of 3.4 is likely
significantly overstating the death rate
and that's good news Trump said the
death rate is probably lower he probably
just got lucky I mean it's not like he
had any special insight it seems that
that's true South Korea's death rate is
0.7 the u.s. death rate is 0.3 that's
great it is not like the flu in almost
any other way and so you know the
comparison is not not super relevant to
me right the Quran actually goes into
the lungs almost immediately and creates
what's known as a RDS which is a cure
respiratory distress syndrome right and
they have to treat that immediately and
my dad died of it many many years ago
and that we ended up filing a lawsuit
because they even said yes as soon as
suspected you got to treat this instead
they waited 10 days and that was way too
long right anyway tragic ok any one
other really quick question I think who
would you like to see Joe Biden pick as
a running mate you have any choices I
personally like Stacy Abrams I think the
odds of him picking Stacy Abrams are
extremely extremely low but I don't have
any particular I sort of joked he should
pick Barack Obama to be his running mate
and I believe that I know people I know
a lot of people say legally it wouldn't
work I believe legally it would work
it's not actually you know a bona fide
suggestion I'm not sure yet I'm gonna
keep thinking about VP and and we will
see we still have some time for that
Steve from Pasadena thank you so much
for the call I appreciate it